[Music]
James Cameron announced for Avatar
sequels and the last one doesn't even
come out until 2027 it's so far away
what if I don't live them look I know
I'm just a prostitute your mom paid for
but how you ever tried enough vitamins
they're specially formulated
multivitamins that contain over 38 key
nutrients designed to keep people with
an avatar fan body type just barely
alive enough to enjoy all the avatar
sequels and now vitamins come in four
strengths wannabe demons keep me healthy
enough to do all my favorite activities
it depends like what sure uh-huh
sit yep cool but what if I'm already on
my deathbed well if you've already been
diagnosed with a critical condition
you can upgrade to the unobtanium Life
drip it induces a medical coma
preserving just enough brain activity to
allow your eyes to register movement and
when you're all done you're all done Wow
how do you know so much about these new
Biederman's that's a prostitute secret
now vitamins
finally a reason to live
[Applause]